hello this is Steve Kaufman you know I
put up a video on youtube about
multilingualism and I was very surprised
at the positive response i think i have
had more response to this video than to
just about any other video that I've
made other than the one on the whole
LPGA Korean golfers thing which
generated a lot of flap but no there was
very positive response from people and
so I want to pursue this and I want I
want to have response more response i
want to ask you out there you know how
do we develop this thing the idea is the
fundamental idea is that it is natural
to speak more than one language in fact
there's two ideas that are central to to
what I what I'm interested in and
hopefully what you're interested in
those of you who responded and out
there's more of you out there it's
natural to speak more than one language
but in order to learn another language
you have to learn it naturally and what
happens today is that that language
learning has become a subject at school
that is taught not learn taught in ways
that d motivate people so and then I
think many people say well I don't need
another language or one another language
alright if you don't want it fine but
but recognize that that the way our
brains are constituted we are in fact
designed to speak and to understand more
than one language it's natural so what I
want to do is I want to create something
and i was thinking of names here you
know multilingualism it's it sounds a
bit elitist to see some people say well
tease I've got trouble speaking my own
language or I never could even learn
French or Spanish at school and now
you're talking about multi-language I
also think the word polyglot is a very
unpleasant word in English although it's
used a lot linguist I like the word
linguist for someone who speaks more
than one language the Oxford Dictionary
defines it that way but a lot of you
think a linguist is someone who who
studies languages and
up with theories you know about how we
learn some kind of an academic approach
to two languages which is not what we
want we just want people to speak and
and most people who speak another
language they didn't learn in the
classroom they learned outside the
classroom they weren't watching TV they
learn with their friends they learn in
natural ways so I'm thinking we could
call this the natural language society I
mean we've had the friend the Flat Earth
Society how about a natural language
society can we can we develop chapters
in amongst people in social circles book
clubs at universities at places of work
wherever people meet and and try to get
people interested in the idea that it is
natural to speak more than one language
and you don't have to speak the second
language perfectly in fact you never
will speak it perfectly but you can get
a tremendous amount of enjoyment out of
learning another language using another
language and in fact more than one
language we're quite capable of handling
four five six seven languages that's the
way our brain works and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to try to maybe put
out more frequent youtube videos talking
about different aspects of natural
learning examples of people will have
naturally learn different languages
maybe some examples of how teachers make
it complicated and difficult for people
to learn talk about people who have
started up maybe branches of the natural
language society get togethers meetings
people may have ideas of things that we
can do can we create some excitement and
I'm open to by the way if you think we
should call this something else fine let
me know but for the time being I'm I
kind of like the idea of natural
language natural language society is
natural to speak more than one language
and but you've got to learn it naturally
so I'm just gonna and I'm going to try
to keep my videos shorter again I'd be
open to suggestions from other people
and I'm going to speak primarily in
English but I'm quite happy because I
think that's most people understand
some English and I don't I mean I can do
them in Spanish Japanese French and so
but I'm happy to do live in other
languages but I want to appeal to the
broadest possible audience however if
someone wants me to repeat any of these
ideas in any other languages that I'm
capable of speaking please let me know
and I'll be quite happy to do them in
other languages and maybe other people
can also produce videos of their own on
youtube as part of the natural language
society and they can do it in their
language and in fact I would look
forward to hearing people expound on the
natural language concept in a variety of
languages some of which I know and some
of which I may not know but if it's a
subject of interest I know that I could
learn the language just from hearing
them and reading in the language and
having enjoyable input and this one last
point I will be talking in future about
two people that have really influenced
me other than my own experience of
language learning and that is stephen
krashen and now Manfred Spitzer stephen
krashen from his experience of language
teaching emphasizes the importance of
meaningful input and Manfred Spitzer
explains exactly how the brain works and
how it learns naturally all the time and
that's what we want we want natural
language learning natural language usage
we want to get the natural language
society going I look forward to hearing
your comments thank you for listening
bye for now